vous l'avez entendu la situation
inquiète l'union africaine qui a
condamné dans un communiqué je cite le
traitement différent inacceptable
choquant et raciste ce phénomène va à
l'encontre des valeurs que défend
l'union européenne comme nous
l'expliquent gauthier rybinski écoutez
si on veut montrer d'abord que cette
guerre sert à quelque chose c'est de
détruire le système coûté une putin
fonctionne sur des théories des théories
pardo raciale et racialiste sur ce
qu'est être russes donc il n'y a aucune
raison pour que des citoyens africains
noirs ou arabes soient traités de la
sorte au motif qu'ils ne soient pas
blanc parce que sinon euh pardonnez moi
mais ça fout tout par terre donc il
s'agit pas maintenant de transiger il il
faut attendre de manière très ferme que
les autorités polonaises comme
ukrainienne ne fasse pas de tri parce
que les africains qui sortent d'ukraine
sont comme les autres des personnes
menacées et que précisément si on veut
que l'europe rue d'or son blason dans
cette affaire ça consiste aussi à
traiter en parfaite équité les citoyens
de quelque pays que ce soit alors je
sais bien c'est compliqué il ya des
problèmes administratifs de consulats de
transport des personnes très bien mais
nous avons vu des images et que là on
n'a pas encore vu tout à fait mais des
images où on voit par exemple des
policiers qu'ils soient eux craignant
polonais rejeter des africains pour
occupy qu'il ne puisse pas monter dans
un train ça n'est pas tolérable
d'ordinaire ça ne l'est pas ça l'est
encore moins parce que si ce qui se joue
dans cette guerre c'est pas des
questions de territoire c'est des
questions aussi de dignité humaine